Ho disegnato Anita nel mio posto
preferito il
[Musica]
cimitero Slime
Challenge questa nuova Challenge oggi si
sfideranno Team Arcobaleno unicorni e
Team mercoledì
[Musica]
nero io sarò l'arbitro di queste
Challenge e per ognuna di queste
assegnerò un e lo deciderò solo io a
quale Team assegnarlo le squadre si
sfideranno in quattro Challenge e per
ognuna di queste quattro Challenge la
squadra che vincerà si aggiudicherà un
premio Io sono Anita del team Arcobaleno
unicorni Io sono Gemma del team
Arcobaleno unicorni Io sono mercoledì
del team nero Io sono mini mercoledì del
team nero E adesso diamo il via alla
prima Challenge
sì
prima Challenge dovete fare il ritratto
del team avversario Potete utilizzare
tutti i colori che volete vincerà il
team che farà il ritratto più bello e
ora Via Col
tempo noi useremo tutti i colori
dell'arcobaleno perché siamo il team
Arcobaleno Sì chissà come reagiranno le
mercoledì quando vedranno il loro
ritratto tutto colorato Secondo te come
reagiranno m
arrabbiate vedremo Sì Gemma Facciamo
così Io disegno mercoledì grande e tu
disegni mini mercoledì ok perfetto
iniziamo
[Musica]
subito abbiamo scelto i nostri colori
preferiti abbiamo aggiunto anche il
marrone era un pochino più
allegro qualsiasi altro colore che non
sia questo ci fa venire la
[Musica]
nausea no no no no
sono sicura che vinceremo noi la
Challenge questo disegno mette i brividi
il mio ritratto sta uscendo
coloratissimo proprio Arcobaleno Non
vedo l'ora di vedere la reazione delle
mercoledì quando vedranno il loro
ritratto Non vedo l'ora di vedere i
premi Spero che vinceremo
noi oh Oh ciao mano Ti piace il mio
disegno Guarda ho fatto Gemma che sta
cadendo in un buco nero fa proprio
ridere Ehi A che punto siete Il tempo
sta per scadere e voi per quale Team ti
fate per il team Arcobaleno o per il
team mercoledì se ti fate per il team
Arcobaleno lasciate un mi piace se
invece ti fate per il team mercoledì
iscrivetevi al
canale ah l'avete sentito Il tempo è
scaduto andiamo a vedere chi ha vinto la
Challenge Perfetto Io tanto ho
finito Non vedo l'ora di vedere come
sarà il premio e io non vedo l'ora di
vedere il ritratto che hanno fatto di
noi le mercoledì ed ora Cominciamo con
il team mercoledì presto mostratemi i
vostri disegni io ho disegnato Anita nel
mio posto preferito il
cimitero io al
cimitero e sta riposando dentro una bara
Guardate che carina
eh
sì spaventoso questo ritratto Ok
passiamo al prossimo allora mini
mercoledì io invece ho disegnato Gemma
che sta cadendo nella mambuca che Ho
scavato qualche giorno fa
Oh Che strano quel disegno è divertente
il mio disegno
vero Diciamo che più che altro mette i
brividi
Ah grazie Che bel complimento che il
complimento più bello che abia mai
ricevuto immagino ma adesso Passiamo al
Team Arcobaleno andiamo e voi dimm
Arcobaleno com'è andata allora Ecco qua
il mio ritratto di mercoledì ho deciso
di fare mercoledì stile Arcobaleno tutta
colorata perché mercoledì è sempre tutta
nera e si veste tutto di nero Quindi ho
deciso di darle un po' di colori ma
quanti colori ha usato Che schifo e tu
Gemma Mostrami il tuo
disegno Io ho fatto mini mercoledì con
tantissimi colori anche più
dell'arcobaleno Wow quanti colori è
super colorato
ah Che cos'è questi colori mi fanno
venire la nausea adesso ci vomito sopra
uh
[Musica]
ho scelto il vincitore di questa
Challenge ed è il team Arcobaleno
[Musica]
Sì abbiamo
vinto dopo tutti quei bellissimi
Complimenti Mi aspettavo che vincessimo
noi ed ecco il premio che va al
vincitore della prima Challenge
T sono delle caramelle coloratissime
se voi le volete dividere con L'arbitro
Io sono qui eh vi posso aiutare a
finirle il prima
possibile
Prano assaggiami subito che
bella la volete dividere una con
l'arbitro no nostre le abbiamo vinte noi
m m che buona questa e ora è arrivato il
momento del saluto del giorno se anche
voi volete essere salutati cliccate un
mi piace sotto a questo video Guardate
questo video fino alla fine poi scrivete
nei commenti Qual è stato il vostro
momento preferito e oggi salutiamo Lina
che ci ha scritto la mia parte preferita
è stata quando Nico e Lucy Vi hanno
messo nel sacco questo è il video in cui
sopravviviamo ai lavori nella vita reale
Eccolo qua se non lo avete visto alla
fine di questo video andate a vederlo ed
è anche uscito il mio nuovo libro La
città stregata dove dentro troverete
l'alfabeto segreto con cui comunicheremo
tanti messaggi segreti insieme e per i
primi ordini Riceverete in regalo questo
poster con me Merlino autografato Quindi
se ancora non ce l'avete cliccate subito
nel link in descrizione Per ordinarlo
seconda Challenge mini mercoledì e gemba
dovrete tatuare sul braccio della vostra
compagna un tatuaggio e vincerà chi farà
il tatuaggio più bello Si
comincia speriamo di vincere anche
questa Challenge Disegnami quello che
vuoi basta che sia colorato Come il
nostro team Arcobaleno Va bene sì
via mano Secondo te cosa possiamo
disegnare sul
braccio un teschio perfetto però mi
raccomando usa solo il nero Certamente
Quali altri colori vuoi che
usi Wow il mio tatuaggio sta uscendo
Bellissimo È anche coloratissimo come no
Team bravissima mini mercoledì sta
uscendo Bellissimo questa Challenge la
vinceremo noi mi sto impegnando
tantissimo tempo scaduto Fermi tutti
presto Nita Mostrami il tatuaggio Ecco
qua il tatuaggio fatto da Gemma Che
cos'è Gemma Wow sono delle cose che
appartengono al nostro team delle cose
che appartengono al vostro Team ci
appartengono una stella un
arcobaleno un cuore e un cuore con
scritto il nostro nome Oh ma è una cosa
tenerissima questa presto adesso
Passiamo all'altro Team allora e adesso
è il turno di mercoledì Mostrami il tuo
tatuaggio Wow Ma questo tatuaggio è
reale è bellissimo Sei stata bravissima
mini mercoledì è super preciso mi piace
un sacco lo sapevo che ero brava a fare
queste cose e ora è il momento di
aggiudicare il premio di questa seconda
Challenge vince il team di mercoledì e
si aggiudica il libro di Anita Stories e
voi Mi raccomando se non ce l'avete
andate a prenderlo subito nelle librerie
oppure su Amazon c'è il link in
descrizione ed ecco qua il premio per
mini mercoledì Wow non vedo l'ora di
leggerlo ci sono tante storie paurosi
Qui sì Sapevo che avremo vinto noi Batti
il cinque terza Challenge questa
Challenge prevede un gioco di squadra
infatti ogni membro del team dovrà
disegnare dietro la schiena su un foglio
un disegno che l'altro membro del team
deve ricopiare stando attento a quello
che sente dietro la schiena sulla
lavagna si è capito Oh non lo so se l'ho
capito nemmeno io ma presto diamo il via
alla Challenge
adesso mi raccomando mini mercoledì
dobbiamo vincere anche questa sfida
adesso tutti giri
e Io disegnerò qualcosa dietro la tua
schiena nel foglio e tu dovrai
ricopiarla qua alla lavagna Ok dovrai
capire che cosa ho disegnato Ok Ci
[Musica]
sto e cosa Sta disegnando mini mercoledì
mercoledì io ho finito di disegnare fai
vedere mettiamo a
confronto Beh dai sono un pochino
simili adesso tocca a noi Team unicorni
sei pronta Sì
[Musica]
vai finito il disegno io non c' ho
capito niente Spero che si assomigli
almeno un pochettino a quello che hai
disegnato tu St un po' scaduto e ora è
il momento di controllare i
[Musica]
risultati letteralmente
diverso Oh No è diverso da quello che ho
disegnato io Io pensavo che fosse un
fiore e invece era un
fiocchetto Ho disegnato questo F
giochetto che c'an nei capelli io ho
disegnato il mio animale domestico una
tarantola sicuramente Qui abbiamo un
vincitore e questo vincitore è il team
degli unicorni è riuscito a fare un
disegno Quasi giusto almeno abbiamo il
gambo il gambo del fiore che conduce più
o meno a questo a questo filo che è qui
in questo fiocco Quindi per me il
vincitore è il team
[Applauso]
unicorni buffa abbiamo perso il disegno
non è uscito benissimo ma sicuramente
andremo meglio nella prossima Challenge
alla prossima volta dovremmo vincere e
sbattere via quegli unicorni spiaccicati
ed ecco il premio che si aggiudica il
team
Unicorn sono delle caramelle Liquide al
gusto di mirtillo fragola e limone anche
in questo caso Se le volete condividere
con l'arbitro sono sempre qui e adesso
quarta e ultima Challenge Slime challeng
Challenge
sìì ognuna delle squadre dovrà fare uno
Slime e vincerà ci farà lo Slime più
bello avvicinatevi alla cattedra per
scegliere le vostre decorazioni e colori
presto allora Gemma Di che colore
facciamo lo Slime scegli dei colori
arcobaleno lo voglio fare Quindi abbiamo
bisogno di tanti colori Sì tanti allora
Rosa secondo me non deve mancare Sì e
poi arancione poi eh verde uh Viola Sì
blu Wow Ah dai l'ultimo l'ultimo Lilla
bellissimo e qua Abbiamo tantissimi
glitter colorati quali scegliamo Non lo
so che sono tutti bellissimi Ah sono
indecisa questo Viola è bellissimo poi
sì poi prendiamone uno rosso o rosa Sì
arancione per fare l'arcobaleno Sì verde
acqua Sì bello è anche blu è giallo
Facciamo così l'ultimo colore sceglilo
con gli occhi chiusi
Sì hai pescato il color oro
Bellissimo direi che abbiamo tutto per
fare il nostro Slime e voi mercoledì
Quali colori Scegliete forza mercoledì
Scegli tu i colori che più preferisci
allora prendo questo bellissimo e
terrificante n Ah ottima scelta poi
questo bellissimo Viola che ha anche un
po' di mix con il nero
m bello secondo te quale altro colore
potremmo usare Secondo me possiamo
scegliere questo verde acqua sporca che
dici sì sarebbe perfetto e invece per i
glitter cosa scegliamo di
glitter
sceglierei questo grigio molto
brillantinato
bellissimo poi poi Eh questo
Viola
e stavo pensando anche di colorarlo un
pochino di blu quindi questo blu di
notte potrebbe uscire un bellissimo
Slime Galaxy ecco a voi la colla per lo
Slime colla trasparente Sì così uscirà
ancora più bello
Evviva Wow W Potete iniziare Sì sì che
colore mettiamo per primo Allora ho
un'idea se noi mettiamo tutti i colori
assieme adesso si mischieranno tutti e
uscirà un colore brutto tipo marrone
scuro Quindi prima dobbiamo mettere i
glitter solidificare lo Slime poi lo
dividiamo in tanti pezzettini e li
coloriamo ognuno così uscirà lo Slime
Arcobaleno Va bene ok Allora iniziamo
con i glitter Scegli tu quale vuoi
mettere Quale vuoi Voglio prima questo
qua Vai
Mettilo che bello questo colore tieni
Mischi Sì lo mischio adesso
Wow aggiungiamolo
po' vediamo con il blu
aggiungiamo
bellissimo
Wow È bellissimo
e anche a voi la colla
Wow Potete iniziare Dai presto uscirà
uno Slime bellissimo dai iniziamo scegli
il colore e iniziamo prima con quello
più chiaro questo ok mettiam Un po' di
gocce forza
mischia che bel colore
Wow
Che bello sta uscendo super
brillantinato ti piace Sì è bellissimo
Adesso andiamo a solidificare lo Slime
per attivarlo Ci basta un po' di
soluzione per
lenti Ecco qua e poi un pizzico di
bicarbonato di
sodio e ora Gira gira
gira
adesso io metto questo
Viola
[Musica]
mischiamo Wow sta diventando più scuro
adesso Passiamo ai
glitter Io metto questi blu e io questi
[Musica]
Viola
Wow
proviamo a
[Musica]
mischiare Wow Sembra una
galassia adesso Io metterò questi
glitter grigi e io questi bianchi per
dare la sensazione delle stelle
Vai wow wow
[Musica]
mischiamo sta diventando bellissimo
Guardate sembra davvero una galassia è
stupefacente forza adesso dobbiamo
attivarlo Grazie mano per avermi portato
il bicarbonato però adesso lascialo
molla
dai poi te lo faremo vedere bene lo
Slime forza rimani qui bene Prendiamo un
pizzichino di bicarbonato e
aggiungiamolo allo
Slime mischia
[Risate]
forza e adesso aggiungiamo un pochino di
soluzione per
[Musica]
lenti
T il nostro Slime è pronto ma manca
ancora una cosa dobbiamo mettere i
colori per fare uno Slime Arcobaleno
Come il nostro team quindi per colorarlo
stacchiamo dei pezzettini è ancora un
po' appiccicoso ma piano piano diventerà
sempre meno appiccicoso Allora
appoggiamo qua i vari pezzetti di Slime
che ci servono da colorare Ok abbiamo
diviso lo Slime in sette pezzi per
colorare ogni pezzo e fare poi lo Slime
Arcobaleno Iniziamo prima con il primo
pezzettino Che colore vuoi mettere Gemma
voglio mettere il rosso mettine solo una
goccina Mi raccomando Altrimenti si
colora
troppo Ok
perfetto Ecco qua i nostri sette colori
di Slime ora per farli Arcobaleno li
posizioniamo tutti così 1
e du si stanno già
attaccando
6 e 7
l'ultimo prendiamo tutto lo Slime e lo
mischiamo così
e Ecco qua il nostro Rainbow Slime ti
piace sì eccolo qua Vi piace E ora ci
giochiamo un po' Sì sì ora lo possiamo
mischiare Ma una volta mischiato non
avrà più il colore Rainbow ma vi
diventerà di un solo colore vediamo di
che colore diventa sì
Vediamo
[Musica]
Wow Guardate quanto è glitterato
facciamo una
[Applauso]
[Musica]
bolla Questo è il nostro Slime Galaxy è
uscito
bellissimo Guardate tutti i
glitter
Wow
Wow che bel
rumore tempo
scaduto controlliamo gli Slime iniziamo
dal vostro
Oh questo è il Rainbow Slime che è stato
unito quindi è diventato di un unico
colore ma vediamo come si presenta Oh
che bello è super glitterato e adesso
andiamo a vedere quello del team di
mercoledì Questo è il Galaxy Slime del
team delle mercoledì è super fluffosa È
strabello il colore mi piace tanto e poi
la consistenza è davvero morbidosa
Vediamo come si
presenta Wow Ma è davvero
bellissimo Che bello io davvero non so
quale scegliere tra i due siccome
l'arbitro Vitale non sa che vincitore
scegliere scegliete voi se vince il team
unicorni o il team mercoledì scrivete
nei commenti Chi ha fatto lo Slime più
bello e vediamo chi ha
[Musica]
vinto Basta con quel
[Applauso]
cellulare Io sono mercoledì Adams la
vostra maestra per
oggi mercoled di Adams è la nostra
maestra per oggi fa paura ma noi abbiamo
il mio nuovo libro La città stregata a
proteggerci e ora disponibile per il
preordine i primi che lo preordino
riceveranno il regalo il poster
autografato con l'alfabeto segreto
quindi preordino subito cliccate nel
link in descrizione ma ora stiamo
attenti alla lezione perché noi siamo Io
sono e io sono Frank e ho un po' di
paura della maestra Io sono William il
popolare della scuola Anzi mi correggo
Il più popolare mercoledì come nuova
insegnante sì mi interessa ma poco
sinceramente ho altro a cui pensare tipo
tutti i miei follower un nuovo bersaglio
per i bulli Gigo eh È
bellissimi Non vedo l'ora sarà una
vittima
facile silenzio e iniziamo subito con la
prima lezione questa prima lezione sarà
sulle creature più spaventose di
Halloween che spero vi torturer anno
stanotte Ah a questa lezione dovrò stare
attentissimo perché così ad Halloween
potrò crearmi da solo l'abito più
spaventoso di tutti eed essere
ovviamente il più seguito su tutti i
social Sì mostruosi Mai quanto quelli
che hanno meno di 20.000 follower Ehi
hai portato quello che ti detto ieri
Ovvio Oh sì così possiamo fare il primo
scherzo a questa maestra chi si crede
chiss
chi vai vai
vai cosa
naturale dobbiamo stare super attenti a
come riconoscere le creature spaventose
Sì hai ragione Quello lì mi sembra un
lupo mentre quello non so proprio cos'è
credo che sia un ragno Ma a proposito di
lupo mannaro Ce n'è anche uno qua nella
copertina e infatti nella nuova storia
nel nuovo mistero da risolvere La città
stregata c'è una trasformazione di un
lupo mannaro c'è un lupo mannaro anche
qua è perfetto per Halloween pre
ordinatelo subito chi osa interrompere
la mia lezione con le sue inutili e
insignificanti
parole cosa state facendo con questo
quello è il mio libro mi
serve pa ora
misteri personaggi spaventosi Io adoro
le cose spaventose questo libro adesso è
mio Cè ancora tuo sì
Nascondilo pauroso questo Questo libro è
pieno di
misteri pensi quello che penso io e cioè
che questa è l'occasione giusta esatto
vado quello vai vai
[Musica]
Guarda guarda si spaventerà tantissimo
se la farà addosso
sì
entusiasmante ma adesso ricominciamo la
lezione sulle creature
[Musica]
spaventose Ma è bellissima
vieni qua cucciolina quanto sei bellina
tarantola sarai il mio nuovo gattino
domestico Ma come non Sii spaventata
animale
domestico il nostro ragno ma non ha
funzionato il nostro scherzo Chi è stato
a mettere questa tarantola pelosa nella
lavagna lui lui No
lui è stato lui S guardi maestra guardi
Guardi Ma chiunque sia stato Grazie È
sempre stato il mio sogno fin da piccola
ho sempre voluto una tarantola Eh sì io
Io no io io io fatto io Beh allora
Grazie per questo regalo siete già i
miei preferiti della classe amici
follower Guardate cosa è successo alla
lezione della maestra mercoledì che
schifo quel ragno gigante sembra
velenoso e quindi pericoloso
Che schifo Io sono l'acn
fobica Wow i selfie col mio nuovo iPhone
37,5 super Gig
xyw escono veramente benissimo me l'ha
comprato nuovo nuovo il mio papi
ovviamente noi ce lo possiamo permettere
Non come voi secchioni che siete ancora
Fermi all'iPhone 2 è talmente nuovo che
non gli ho tolto ancora neanche la
pellicola Ma guarda questo viziato che
con quel telefono
Che emozione è talmente antipatico che
io un giorno ha quell' iPhone super mega
ultra e tutti gli ambaradan glielo rubo
glielo ridò e poi glielo Gli rubo
benissimo così ci rimane male due volte
adesso seconda
lezione pozioni adesso create la vostra
pozione con gli ingredienti che avete a
disposizione sul banco ma state attenti
perché tra gli ingredienti c'è un veleno
mortale e chi ha studiato sa
riconoscerlo Mentre chi non ha studiato
Beh Peggio per lui
oh io non ho studiato Tu hai studiato
Secondo te No ma infatti noi non
studiamo mai dobbiamo andare a casa per
forza Oh ti troverò Scegli con
attenzione eh Sei tu allora io prendo
questa vai cincin alla salute Spero non
sia quella mortale nel caso la do a bere
a Frankie no tocca a me questo non ha un
bruttissimo colore Spero che non sia il
veleno mortale Guarda che colore strano
Oh ma puzza di di ascella di maestra
Santina Che schifo fa proprio schifo Ma
che schifo di colori sono quelli
veramente non vi dico cosa sembrano si
vede proprio che siete due poveracci non
come me il mio colore sarà Bellissimo Si
abbinerà tutto il mio guardaroba e poi
io ho questa ampolla super mega 3000 XY
XL non come le vostre Dunque Oh la mia
diretta quotidiana non faccia a
dimenticarmene ragazzi Vi rendete conto
con questa sfida rischio di morire cioè
io tipo #tag scioccato Chissà che colore
verrà
fuori No vabbè è lo stesso colore della
Chevrolet del papi sarà fierissimo di me
questa sfida è facilissima per noi
secchioni perché noi abbiamo studiato
e Sappiamo benissimo che quella mortale
è questa nera vero
Sì quindi prendiamo un altro colore
giusto Ehi ma che fai è quella mortale
quella Ma tu sei secchione dovresti aver
studiato Esatto ma son così intelligen
che ho capito che mischiando boccetta
verde con boccetta blu si ottiene una
cosa benefica e non la morte meglio non
Ok Tieni Usa questa
bella Wow che bel colore la mia pozione
più bella è la mia più
intelligente Guardate che pozione
meravigliosa che ho creato non di certo
come quella della secchiona Anita
Guardate che schifo di colore Ehi ma
come ti permetti la mia pozione è
perfetta Anche perché io ho studiato
chissà cosa c'è nella tua di pozione beh
Cosa c'è Non mi interessa So solo che è
un bellissimo colore e si abbina con
tutta la mia paletta di colori
della William Basta con quel
[Musica]
cellulare dammi quel telefono No la
prego qua dentro c'è tutta la mia vita
dammelo folla brutto
[Musica]
scoro facciamo fare al tuo nuovo iPhone
un bel bagnetto
Così
[Musica]
[Applauso]
impari
[Musica]
come farò adesso tutti i miei follower
Mi sentite follower
[Musica]
Beh a dire il vero un po' gli sta bene
al Popolare era troppo antipatico Sì
quel bambino viziato ha preso quello che
meritava Adesso ho un iPhone
fluff Troppo divertente questa lezione
bene adesso Passiamo alla terza e ultima
lezione che si terrà all'aperto in
questa terza lezione vi inseg erò a
trovare il posto giusto dove scavare una
fossa per dormire ovviamente m vediamo
chi chiamare per scavare Beh tu Billy
Vieni subito qua visto che hai
disturbato tutta la lezione forza scava
Ma perché proprio io devo scavare non
lamentarti non so se ci riesco e va bene
ci
provo Forza dei bulli a
me Oh ma SEO
fortissimo gli sta bene a Billy almeno
non ha chiamato a me ma chi se ne frega
a me non interessa solo del mio telefono
non so più cosa fare senza Ehi
Anita
Ehi voi che cosa state scog ditando
Adesso vi seppellirò nella buca che sta
facendo Billy Ehi voi ma perché non ci
alleiamo tutti tutti e tre insieme così
la facciamo pagare ai Bulli e alla
maestra che mi ha buttato il telefono
nell'acqua Sì esatto Mi sembra che tra
loro ci sia un grande legame Sì è vero
dobbiamo riuscire a difenderci da loro
restiamo uniti contro i bulli e contro
mercoledì Complimenti Billy stai andando
molto bene grazie maestra e comunque le
volevo dire maestra è un'ottima idea
quella di seppellire i secchioni e il
popolare e io bullo E Sì sì son qui noi
l' aiuteremo ad effettuare il suo piano
Sì sì sì grazie mille siamo pronti siamo
pronti Oh sì se siamo
pronti avete sentito vogliono
seppellirci nella fsta dobbiamo fare
qualcosa Ho un'idea il
libro
Guardate Ehi ma dove sono cosa mi è
successo Ehi ehi cosa mi avete fatto con
i poteri del libro l'abbiamo
rimpicciolita Come vi siete permessi a
fare questa perc di Adams ve la farò
pagare cosa gli hanno fatto qua le cose
si mettono molto male dobbiamo scappare
scappiamo
scappiamo Così impari a terrorizzare i
secchioni e a buttarmi il telefono
nell'acqua Esatto io non ci vedo Mettiti
gli
occhiali forse voi non sapete con che
avete a che fare benenti sta
mercoledì ora rimani minuscola non
potrai più terrorizzare nessuno al
massimo le formiche Beccatevi
[Musica]
questa mercoledì mercoledì
mercoledì
oho non mi sono mai divertita così tanto
nemmeno un funerale
Barbie contro mercoledì
uh
sì Ciao Noi siamo il team delle
mercoledì e io sono mercoledì Alice e
lui è Io sono mercoledì Vitale e sono il
sorello di mercoledì e lei è io sono
mercoledì psicopatica e sono la sorella
di mercoledì e noi siamo il team delle
Barbie Io sono Barbie Anita e lei lui
lei è Barbie francona la Barbie rossa e
lei Io sono Barbie grangala
un'aristocratica
ci sfideremo in una serie di Challenge
per vedere se vincono le Barbie o le
mercoledì prima Challenge
Sì la prima Challenge sarà una Challenge
di sopravvivenza fuori all'aperto
Vediamo chi riesce più a sopravvivere
fuori nella natura noi Barbie o le
mercoledì Ah noi Barbie ci stiamo
organizzate benissimo per questa
esperienza nella natura infatti abbiamo
organizzato un picnic con tantissim cibo
e anche una copertina per sederci Come
delle vere Barbie aristocratiche Sì
esatto cara Ho portato anche delle altre
merendine Perfetto grazie Barbie
figurati Barbie Secondo me le mercoledì
non ce la faranno a sopravvivere nella
natura sicuramente moriranno di fame Io
odio la natura Io odio la luce del sole
Io odio stare più di 15 minuti senza
mangiare tranquillo Vitale trovero una
soluzione Non possiamo perdere la
Challenge Eh no ma tu hai portato da
mangiare no E tu no Io ho già
mangiato però Sento odore di cibo
sentite anche
voi
Guarda le Barbie hanno portato da
mangiare Oh sì è tanto andiamo a
rubarglielo
sì Ah si sta benissimo vinceremo
sicuramente noi la Challenge Ciao Barbie
che buon profumo che c'è qua quanta roba
ma non la volete condividere un po' con
noi no perché dobbiamo vincere noi la
Challenge questa è roba nostra ma io
sono affamato qui non mi interessa
Sloggi E se io faccio
così
bravissime siamo riusciti a scacciarlo
il mercoledì Mi sa proprio che abbiamo
vinto noi questa
Challenge è stato troppo difficile siamo
stati scacciati già ma io ho
un'idea spaventiamo le e facciamole
scappare Oh
sì forza andiamo
via Allora Barbie Perché non parliamo
male di Ken adesso Sì assolutamente Come
va col tuo Ken Barbie abbastanza bene e
a
te io non ho un Ken ancora non l'hai
trovato per Ken non posso avere un Ken
Il mio invece è acculturato è un
principe
Wow Fortunata Ah che meraviglia sembra
di stare a Barbie
[Musica]
Land Eccomi eccomi ce l'ho fatta questa
volta il nostro piano ha funzionato
adesso si spaventerà e vinceremo noi
finalmente mangeremo e finalmente
andiamo dentro non ce la faccio più con
questo
sole Che schifo sono state le mercoledì
sicuramente Beccatevi
[Musica]
questa pensavano di spaventarci e
rubarci il cibo ma non ci sono riuscite
e quindi la prima Challenge l'abbiamo
vinta noi Barbie forza Team Barbie e ora
seconda Challenge la seconda Challenge
sarà una gara di velocità vediamo se
sono più veloci le mercoledì o le Barbie
[Musica]
via tanto vinceremo noi mercoledì voi
Barbie siete troppo delicate per correre
al massimo potete farlo in una
passerella meglio in una passerella che
in mezzo ai cimiteri
sgorbi vai vai vai ce la puoi
fare tacchi non ci riesco Oh no i tacchi
di Barbie sono troppo scomodi sta
andando lentissima non riuscirà mai a
raggiungere
[Musica]
Mercoledì ho vinto io Barbie sta ancora
lì non mi sono mai divertita così tanto
nemmeno un
funerale non sono mai stata umiliata
tanto
Barbie Uffa Barbie grangala ha perso ma
ora proverò io a vincere perché io non
ho i tacchi oggi Neanch'io ho i tacchi
oggi Barbie Barbie Barbie
Barbie mercoledì mercoledì
mercoledì Barbie
[Musica]
Barbie Guarda guarda c'è una pizza pizza
dov' la pizza Oh la pizza Oh
si è cascato ce l'ho fatta Ho vinto io
questo round Dov'è la pizza non l'ho
trovata non c'è nessuna pizza Ho vinto
io Ma come non c'è la
pizza e mi ha ingannato passiamo ora al
terzo round io sono carichissima perciò
corrò un sacco veloce sono sicura che
vincerò io e invece vincerò io copi
Rocca di uno zombie Ehi barbossa Togliti
i tacchi altrimenti per come Barbie Gal
togel presto toglili toglili no è quro
il regolamento non li togliere Non è
vero Ahia hai ragione Grazie Barbie
[Musica]
stereotipo si è tolto i
tacchi cosa sta
succedendo Sì abbiamo vinto lo
sapevo No Abbiamo
perso Sì abbiamo vinto Noi
fiamo
sì che gioia abbiamo vinto davvero
bellissimo Uffa noi Barbie abbiamo perso
questa Challenge ma manca ancora la
terza Challenge che sarà la Challenge
decisiva siete pronte certo quella la
vinciamo di sicuro
esatto
per la terza Challenge avremo una gara
di un veicolo telecomandato e noi
ovviamente abbiamo scelto la scer rosa
di Barbie Wow È bellissima ed è Rosa ed
è bella e speriamo che sia anche
velocissima per battere le mercoledì
Vediamo loro cosa hanno scelto Noi
mercoledì abbiamo scelto qualcosa che ci
rappresenta sì scarafaggio è piccolo ma
sicuramente riuscirà a battere le Barbie
è velocissimo e si
[Musica]
spaventerà aspettate perché non ci V
detto Soto schiaccialo
schiaccialo Ma che cosa stanno facendo
Ci vogliono schiacciare dai no corri
piccolo Gino piccolo Gino
corri
[Musica]
eh non è colpa mia è colpa della
macchina a
[Musica]
sinistro nono neanche guidare una
macchina telecomandata vinceremo Noi sì
Scar St andando alla grande u non riesco
a prenderla ti a sinistra sto girando
intorno C la testra Mi sta venendo il
capoo
[Musica]
senti tieni guida ma non lo so guidare
Dai dai dai Tieni la borsetta non
possiamo farti battere dallo scarabaggio
Ma come funziona questa
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cosa Oh no ci hanno schiacciato come
facciamo
adesso
Oh no non mi dire che abbiamo rotto la
macchina schiacciando lo scarabaggio
nelle mercoledì no no no le cose si
stanno mettendo male Sì sì vai
Gino dai
schiaccio bravissima Mari Choo ano di
nuovo
Oh no qualcosa è andato storto lo SCAR
fagio non sta andando avanti si sarà
rotto qualcosa non sta
[Applauso]
funzionando Oh no Come abbiamo fatto a
perdere contro le Barbie abbiamo solo
avuto sfortuna ma in certi casi la
sfortuna ci
piace in questo caso no
ah Cappuccetto Rosso S lei la mia
merenda eh eh
ehi anche a voi Hanno fatto degli
scherzi ho sparito qualcosa è fatto sì
il
lupo ver oggi campeggio di
Halloween Challenge Io sono la strega e
io farò il vampiro e questa è la nostra
tenda da campeggio di
oggi Io sono brom brom il pagliaccio e
io sono mercoledì Adams Se questa è la
nostra
tenda Io sono Katy La gatta nera e io
sono Frankie il lupo mannaro e questo è
il nostro Castello mio ed è così grande
che ci entra solo
[Musica]
kety
Ah buongiorno qua nella tenda di me
strega preparo la colazione nel mio
calderone mm Ehi ciao sono l'emoji di
Anita e ho un gioco per te Prova a
lasciare mi piace entro 5 secondi 5 4 3
2 1 tempo scaduto ci sei
riuscita proprio quello che ci vuole la
mattina questa luce questa Lucia mi sta
facendo diventare cieco Capisco che per
voi è mattina ma io sono un vampiro e a
quest'ora i vampiri vanno a dormire
quindi
buonanotte nella mia Morning Routine
devo sempre truccarmi da pagliaccio e
farmi il naso ma in realtà io il naso ce
l'ho
già che bella giornata per fare tanti
[Risate]
scherzi mi dispiace tarantola l'allegria
di questo Pagliaccio ti ha fatta
svegliare io non lo sopporto più vado a
farlo stare
zitto Non ti preoccupare Tu rimani
qui senti pagliaccio vuoi stare zitto Ma
è una così bella giornata possiamo fare
tanti scherzi ti va di fare degli
scherzi con me
no Che bello vederti così contenta Ma
perché sei così giù ho capito cosa ti ci
vuole una bella risata Allora il mio
trucco magico
è rubarti il nasino ti ho rubato il
nasino ma prima o poi riuscirò a farti
ridere per ora ti rido il nasino
pagliaccio ce l'ho io qualcosa di
divertente mio dolore mi è caduto anche
il
naso
esilarante Adesso mi preparo per dormire
Sono troppo stanca Sono un gatto nero
non posso rimanere fuori il mio pelo si
rovinerebbe E se piovesse lo potrei
sopportare Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita
sono qua per ricordarvi che è appena
uscito oggi il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo T tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo
[Applauso]
subito Oh non ho più voce ho rulato per
tutta la notte adesso mi ritrovo qui mi
fai un posticino per dormire
Assolutamente no E quindi non puoi farmi
un posticino per dormire al riparo dai
anch'io e il pelo siamo simili non mi
interessa il mio pelo è ben curato il
tuo no insomma guarda quelle unghie che
cos'hanno di brutto le mie unghie sono
bellissime E va bene mi tocca anche oggi
dormire
qui sì eh sì sono pronto sono pronto ma
Quanta luce c'è ma ho sbagliato mi sono
svegliato troppo presto Pensavo di non
aver sentito la sveglia invece ancora
pomeriggio Finalmente è l'ora della
merenda Quindi adesso prendo il mio
bicchiere di sangue e me lo bevo tutto
troppo buono e adesso posso ritornare a
dormire Buonanotte Anzi buongiorno eh
Che schifo Vitale vampiro beve il sangue
molto meglio la mia zuppa dentro gli
schifosi E a proposito di Halloween e
ora disponibile il mio nuovo libro La
città stregata gli investigatori del
mistero Ed è proprio a tema Halloween è
perfetto da leggere per Halloween perché
è un po' pauroso e c'è anche un lupo ma
Naro una trasformazione Se non ce
l'avete ancora cliccate nel link in
descrizione per prenderlo subito oppure
lo trovate in tutte le librerie e questo
è un messaggio segreto per voi che
potete tradurre con alfabeto segreto che
trovate dentro al libro prendetelo
subito è il momento della merenda e io
ho tantissime caramelle colorate tu
mercoledì cos'hai per merenda lacrime e
tristezza sono sicuro che prima o poi
riuscirò a farti ridere Guarda questo
pettine gigante è il momento di uno dei
miei scherzi rimane incastrato non ti fa
[Risate]
ridere anche il naso mi è caduto l'ho
fatta ridere giubilo e
allegria Ti ho fatta ridere della
verità No non è vero non mi hai fatta
ridere e non ci riuscirai mai invece sì
hai riso ti ho visto e ti hanno visto
anche loro Ehi se credete che l'abbia
fatta ridere mettete like ed ecco la mia
merenda un po' di
latte Uffa però Io non ho niente da
mangiare per merenda andrò a rubarla gli
[Musica]
altri
Oh Ci son tante merende Questa è la
pozione della
strega ma sono insetti e questa me la
puoi chiamare merenda questo è il sangue
del
vampiro c'è pure un'unghia
dentro Ma questa è Cappuccetto Rosso
sarà lei la mia
merenda Ehi ma che cosa stai facendo Ma
quale Cappuccetto Rosso non mi vedi che
io sono il bambino Vitale lasciami
dormire vai via di qua
S fammi dormire in pace
guarda Ok ok me ne
vado Dato che quello era Vitale vampiro
ho un bello scherzetto per
lui è l'ora di mangiare qualche
caramella Ah quanto mi piacciono le
caramelle Ah adesso me ne mangio
tantissime
altre ma sono vermi mercoledì cosa vuoi
Sei stata tu a mettermi questi vermi qua
per farmi uno scherzo di Halloween No
non sono stata io invece sì ma dov'è il
mio secchiello dormiva la mia tarantola
lì dentro era lì non lo
so sei stato tu no Dimmi dove hai messo
la mia teranda non l'ho spostata io tu
mi hai messo i vermi non son stata io
invece sì E allora chi è stato a togli
Non lo so ma non io mi hai rubato il
[Musica]
naso È così che si fa un vero scherzo di
Halloween
Brava ok cosa abbiamo collezionato oggi
la scopa della strega il sangue del
vampiro e la tarantola di mercoledì sono
aracnofobico bel bottino oggi però sono
riuscito a ingannarli tutti Sono proprio
bravo
[Musica]
Ah finalmente sono calate le tenebre
Questo è il mio momento preferito della
giornata Ho già tutto pronto per la mia
night
[Musica]
routine
buonanotte ma Marco Tu non dormi no
pagliaccio A me non piace dormire Questo
è il momento perfetto per leggere questo
libro La città stregata Ah ci sono cose
paurose
le mie preferite Anch'io lo vorrei
leggere Oh ma adesso son troppo stanco
per leggerlo Ci penserò domani
Buonanotte
finalmente sveglio tenebre sono pronto
Adesso bevo il mio bel bicchiere di
sangue è aglio chi è che mi ha fatto
questo scherzo mi ha messo l'aglio Che
schifo È il momento di uscire fuori
andiamo scappiamo non ce la posso fare
più con questo taglio via Ah finalmente
la notte è il momento di andare in giro
con la scopa Posso volare sui tetti
finalmente Dov'è la mia scopa qualcuno
l'ha rubata non è possibile
Dov'è Finalmente è la notte ora posso
uscire con i miei occhi da gatta ci vedo
benissimo
miao Ehi pagliaccio
mercoledì Che cosa c'è anche a voi Hanno
fatto degli scherzi ho è sparito
qualcosa fatto sì a me hanno sostituito
le caramelle con dei vermi e a me hanno
rubato la mia
tarantolino e a lui hanno sostituito il
sangue con dell'aglio dell'aglio ti
rendi conto ad un vampiro dare
dell'aglio che vergogna eh È fatto Beh a
me Effettivamente hanno rubato il
latte Ma chi è l'unica persona che manca
qua Adesso vediamo c'è il gatto il
l'elefante il pagliaccio manca solo il
lupo I due leocorni e i due leocorni ci
fno Ma che stai dicendo gatto vampiro
strega pagliaccio mercoledì manca solo
il
lupo è vero manca il lupo io avevo
sbagliato storia stavo pensando al gatto
al toop elefante Però presto troviamo un
modo per intrappolare il lupo
Andiamo Oh che belli questi oggetti sono
riuscita a fregare tutti ho proprio
collezionato un bel
bottino come funziona
questa fregato Proprio tutti ma come
funziona ma si ha spento la luce Beh
volevi la tenda adesso ce l'hai Ah così
impari a rubare le cose e fare gli
scherzi Beccati questo incantesimo
adesso
copriamo Eccolo qua
Il è quello che ti meriti così
[Musica]
impari ha consegnato in bianco
Zero Uh e poi il lampadario comincia a
muoversi come se ci fosse un fantasma
Questa è una parte del mio nuovo libro
Questa è la mia parte preferita Quanto
sono
bella e Billy svegliati guardagli un
verino per fare un sacco di scherzi
siamo a solo
bravo Buongiorno
ragazzi Chi è chi è le Da dove salta
fuori che paura Ma che cos'è È
inquietante
sono la nuova maestra Victoria la vostra
supplente per oggi che strana questa
maestra Chissà perché si è vestita così
eppure oggi non è Halloween non lo so
sarà il suo stile però mi sembra molto
pallida questo
sole passiamo le tende però quel vestito
è davvero carino lo devo ammettere
chissà come mi starebbe e poi la mia
popolarità aumenterebbe ah Adesso si sta
molto meglio Ah una supplente ma io non
volevo fare niente oggi D'altronde ho
anche il cappellino con la A che sta per
A me non piace la
scuola Bravissimo Hai proprio imparato
bene dal il capullo Grazie
Billy
silenzio oggi ci sarà una verifica
scriverò alla lavagna delle domande e
voi le dovrete copiare ma come già una
verifica il primo giorno di supplenza ma
Anita Noi siamo secchioni prenderemo
sicuramente 10 Speriamo verifica Ma no
non ho studiato ma tanto noi non
studieremo comunque e poi come faccio a
scrivere Ho usato il foglio per fare gli
aeroplani di
[Musica]
carta ma che fai Ma stai leggendo tu
idio Ma stai scherzando Non so neanche
Quale è la o e la i Sto preparando il
nostro nuovo scherzo Guarda qua
bellissimo da fare alla nuova maestra Sì
andiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
prepariamoci Avete finito di scrivere No
aspetti aspeta un per favore Dai non mi
interessa cancello lo
[Musica]
stesso Oh
fratellino fratellino Ma come come
fratellino È da mesi che ti
cercavo Adesso tu rimani qui mentre io
faccio la lezione ok Non ha
funzo scherzo Sì ma qui c'è qualcosa di
strano No non è possibile iniziate
subito la verifica gruppo
sanguigno Che cos'è io conosco solamente
cose trendy e è Popular del momento di
quello non ne ho mai sentito parlare le
domande di questa verifica sono
stranissime la prima domanda è qual è il
tuo gruppo sanguigno e la seconda
domanda è hai mangiato aglio Ultimamente
sono stranissime queste domande perché
questa maestra ci fa queste domande tu
hai risposto Beh sì io ho risposto il
mio gruppo sanguigno è ABC negasi io 49
plus ultra Maxi 79 - 24 per 10 Pro ma ne
sei sicuro e c Certo lo so da quando
sono nato e alla seconda domanda Cosa
hai risposto hai mangiato aglio
ultimamente Sì perché ho mangiato
Pastaio olio con
Vitale gruppo sanguigno Che cos'è un
gruppo sanguigno E io che ne so eh Ah no
non è per noi Noi siamo il gruppo dei
bulli quale per il gruppo sanguigno un
altro gruppo Vabbè Copiamo Tanto siamo
dei Jail in
questo R scrivi r
r
[Musica]
stavate copiando
copi tu vieni qui io io mi lasci mi
[Applauso]
lasci Aiutatemi
aiutatemi cosa hai fatto Billy Poverino
Ora
basta finita adesso vi ritiro i
compiti sì non ho scritto niente però va
bene Vabbè chi se ne frega sono un bulbo
Io l'ho finito Ecco maestra io ho
scritto tutte le
[Musica]
risposte ragazzi sì
poco fa quando è passata la maestra a
ritirare le verifiche lo specchio Non la
rifletteva state pensando anche voi
quello a cui penso io
che lo specchio di Jennifer è rotto che
lo specchio riflette solo me forse che è
tempo di fare altri scherzi Dai non vedo
l'ora No sto pensando che la maestra
potrebbe
essere un vero
vampiro disegnato in bianco
Zero Che
schifo guarda ti avrei messo cinque ma
solo per questo
[Musica]
due ha risposto a tutte le domande è
correttamente e non ha mangiato Alo bene
10 quella potrebbe essere la mia
verifica perfetto Questa è andata
proprio bene ok La prima è giusta ma la
seconda ha mangiato l'aglio 10
meno No spero di non essere io ad aver
preso 10 meno sarebbe un colpo al cuore
troppo forte e non lo potrei sopportare
Queste sono le vostre verifiche un
orrore alcune Ma l'ha scrittto con il
sangue Oh no io ho la vista del
sangue Beh almeno ho preso
10 preso
10 10
meno Ah già il compito Zero meglio
dell'altra volta ho preso zero meno la
settimana corsa Sì bene Adesso che ho
raccolto tutte le informazioni su di voi
è arrivato il momento più bello
trasformarvi in
vampiri Ma cosa fa Ah mi sta mordendo
ragazzi aiuto oddio oddio i canini Ah fa
male tutto Aiuto Mi formicolano le
braccia mi sta
trasformando
Adesso è il momento di trasformare anche
voi non pensarci
neanche Ma che cos'è
iio brucia
brucia ce l'abbiamo fatta Abbiamo
sconfitto la maestra vampiro cattiva
Grazie al libro La Sitta stregata che
ora disponibile online in libreria e io
mi sono ritrasformato Grazie
Anita
P